attention je repars en tournée près de
chez vous avec mon spectacle dans lequel
est inclus des nouveautés je serai
bientôt à onet-le-château près de rodez
je serai également à toulouse à
seignosse et près de biarritz je vais
être en belgique à namur à mons à
louvain la neuve à ronan à nantes à hier
à paris à aulnay sous bois poissy à
perpignan que c'était et c'est allé voir
toutes les dates sur le site et surtout
ne tardez pas à réserver
c'est au conseil saluent aujourd'hui
nous allons pas faire un casse tête nous
allons faire pire qu'un casse tête c'est
un jeu très addictif qui s'appelle
perplexus perplexus c'est une marque qui
m'ont envoyé plusieurs de leurs castel
je ne sais pas si on devrait dire casse
tête ou pas en fait parce que c'est une
sorte de labyrinthe mais il n'y a pas à
trouver son chemin dans une boule avec
une vigne et en fait on va devoir la
faire passer partout dans celui ci il ya
100 étape et donc il faut réussir à
faire laissant étape sans tomber une
seule fois c'est assez marrant je vous
le dis c'est addictif on les a reçus il
ya je crois une semaine avec fanny on
passe notre vie dessus fanny est ce que
tu confirmes lui tulle a fini lui moi je
n'ai pas fini en une seule fois et il a
fini en une seule fois non tu veux pas
finir une seule fois en fait on peut ce
drop et à la position numéro une
numéro 2 ça nous emmène au 25 et la
numéro 3 ça nous emmène au 59 et ça
c'est très pratique pour s'entraîner
quand il ya des petits passages délicats
petit drop et directement aux 25 pour
aller t'entraîner un peu à faire les
moves et revenir au point de départ mais
le but c'est de partir au point de
départ et plus tu joues plus tu tombais
plus du ton plus tu améliores ton
agilité ta concentration tad enerdata
taqwa allô oui bonjour c'est pour un mot
oui ta détermination et aussi ta
patience là je vous faire le original je
pense que je ferai les autres aussi sur
la chaîne secondaire de la gamme via le
epic qui est beaucoup plus dur que lui
il ya le rookie ya la version harry
potter je vous ferai les autres sur la
chaîne secondaire la chaîne secondaire
et dans la description
mais les liens vers les perplexus et en
particulier celui là sont dans la
description également parce que ça se
vend sur amazon et dans les magasins de
jouets également vous pouvez les trouver
fait partie loïc génériques de marque
lexus perplexus
alors évidemment c'est le truc le plus
difficile de la planète à filmer parce
que c'est une sphère qu'on doit bouger
dans tous les sens et en plus de ça il
faut bien qu'on éclaire la scène et donc
les éclairages partout qui vont se
refléter mais vous allez voir la mabille
aller au niveau du 1 elle est prête à
partir je vais essayer de tenir le
perplexus comme ça et vous faire voir et
vous allez vite comprendre que ça part
dans tous les sens là je le fais tomber
dans le rail numéro un
pour l'instant il ya des gouttières des
deux côtés ne sera pas toujours le cas
oui là je dois tourner comme ça pour
arriver aux deux est en fait là mon but
c'est de voir jusqu'où je peux aller
sans tomber sachant qu'en plus c'est pas
une excuse mais en plus je fais en sorte
que ce soit pas trop mal filmé la
billette ici je vais me rétablis là est
donc là on est que ie8 sur 100
c'est pas énorme et on va continuer
quand ça tombe alors dans les débuts ça
va et quand ça tombe à la fin tu as
vraiment ça te gêne r1 à soufflement
extrême qui ressemble à hawaï mais n'ont
voulu commenter en fait ils recommencent
parce que tu ne peux pas t'empêcher de
l'ag faire très attention il ya le
cercle de la mort qui revient sur le
serpentin du diable
là c'est la première acrobaties il ya
des espèces d'acrobaties là c'est dans
mon langage à moi je l'appelle la
falaise tortueuse il faut que je
descende ici tout en penchant un peu là
oui c'est bon et là j'arrive là comme
vous voyez et il va falloir que je le
fasse dégueuler parce que j'ai peut être
de terme dans la gouttière orange qui
correspond à 18
j'aime ce jeu ok c'est reparti je viens
de revenir à l'endroit où j'en étais
peut-être ces dames en 1
c'est une galère de vous le faire en
vidéo en fait vous promet pas d'arriver
au numéro 100 je vous promet d'aller le
plus loin possible quand même sinon je
vais être obligée d'ouvrir une chaîne
fabien olicard arts au labyrinthe us
n'ouvrait pas cette chaîne à ma place
merci beaucoup ça mais pourquoi je tombe
là à chaque fois donc je repars 1 2 3 4
5 6 ah oui c'était aux 6 7 8 9
allez va aux dix copains ah oui nous
faut contourner 10 11
nosy adieu 13
14 ok là je vous parle pas parce que je
me concentre on le fait tomber chaque
track voilà ok je suis tombé je suis
tombé au bon endroit dans la bonne
gouttière donc là j'arrive ici là on a
un petit chemin de la mort là au dessus
regardez le petit chemin de la mort qui
est juste là aussi je vérifie dans les
comptes contrôle les juste là c'est tout
dentelée faut mettre assez de forces
pour qu'il gagne quand même l problème
étant que si tu donnes trop de puissance
elle va partir trop loin
donc j'ai inventé la technique du je te
tape dans le dos et là ça marche pas
trop mal comme technique là on va
contourner sur le violet ça vous n'allez
pas trop le voir je pense et on va se
retrouver sur le même rail mais de
l'autre côté parce qu'on a fait à 180
degrés et la haye les rebloquer donc on
retape hot embargo 27 j'aime pas le 27
je vous le dis direct parce que là il ya
une grosse acrobaties à faire ok je la
fais tomber lui clairement vous allez
mal voir aussi peut-être que vous allez
bien voir parce que c'est un peu a
découvert quand même il faut le faire
passer comme ça sur la plateforme allez
vas-y voilà oui bon ok c'est pas le
plusieurs le passage le plus dur pour
moi il est vers les 30 essais il est
juste là d'ailleurs ça c'est mon passage
qui est détesté et détestable
ok je le fais arriver là oui j'ai pas
trop mal même en termes de rapidité
là il va falloir que je pense
complètement de l'autre côté pour le
mettre à plat et il n'y aura pas de
gouttière sur les côtés faudra que je
fasse avancer dans la diagonale opposés
et de là que je suive le contour pour
prendre cet arceau viol et que vous
voyez là par l'intérieur c'est
complètement ouf j'essaie de le faire
bien
à aulas a bâché roman je suis redescendu
juste là où j'en étais vous avez vu les
micro-expressions sur mon visage
ce magnifique ralenti vous est sûrement
offert par loïc ok oui je le laisse
ensuite faux l'homme pourriez tout en
douceur par la ensuite technique de
fanni qui m'a dit ici regarde tout mais
sur le violet et voilà et là je suis
dans l'arceau donc forcément vous ne le
voyez pas et je suis à l'intérieur de
l'arceau hockey et quand on est tout en
bas il faut le maintenir comme ça dans
cette espèce de gouttière la orange à
l'intérieur pour l'emmener aux 34 il ya
cent étape c'est que le 34 l'ain ok là
je viens de tomber dans le 35 cette
petite plateforme amovible convoi
envoyer de l'autre côté après faudra
rectifier l'angle vers le vert en gros
le 35
je le fait basculer ok là vous l'avez vu
et maintenant je vais la déposer comme
ça oui j'y suis ok je commence à faire
gaffe ce qui est un nouveau cap à passer
là je vais essayer de le faire tomber
dans le jaune à savoir le 30/08 à l'efa
on croit en toi oui 39 on rectifie par
là et là tout au bout c'est ricky de ouf
parce que tout au bout attention faut y
aller tout doucement tout doucement
là il faut faire tomber dans la petite
gouttière du jaune qui alla en dessous
oui j'ai les mains ancien lors mon gars
mais laisse tomber ok là je vais arriver
vous l'avez vu passer sur le petit
violet qui alla hockey de l'autre côté
alors je fais très attention parce que
là on va atteindre un petit labyrinthe
que vous découvrez ici et là regardez au
niveau du 47 ya un trou si je vais dans
le trou je tombe donc petit labyrinthe
brasse le faire en douceur comme des
gentlemans voilà et là il n'ya pas de
gouttière aussi vous avez vu entre le 49
et le 50 donc il faut que je me
maintiennent un peu comme ça ok j'y
arrive aux 50
là je passe le gentiment le petit hoquet
et là je peux aller au 51 mais pour
faire tout en douceur aussi toujours à
petit technique de jeter tapote mais
gentiment quand même ok là je vais le
prendre comme ça à voir le 52 et
celui-là il est horrible
vous avez dans un virage un endroit où
il ya plus de gouttière après il ya les
gouttières et après la figure de l'autre
côté pita bingo 52 chez rigaud 50 je
l'avais aussi comme de moitié et passer
50%
je leur fais de fer en accéléré louis
qui mettrait un accéléré parce que je
vais essayer de revenir aux 52
accélération
[Musique]
pause dans l'accélération loïc bon vous
avez vu je suis tombé parce que j'essaie
d'aller vite pour continuer à vous faire
voir le parcours du coup je vais me drop
et aux 25 juste avant le 27 comme ça ça
va me permettre de ré avancé loïc
c'était quoi la musique de
l'accélération
parce que vraiment ce serait bien que
nous l'a dit un jour parce que j'en peux
plus de voir les commentaires de ckoi la
musique de l'accélération
donc vous avez vu là je suis déjà revenu
au 27 en dropant directement au 25
mon but dans cette vidéo c'est d'essayer
de vous faire voir le maxi par tour je
n'ai pas du tout la prétention de battre
un record il y en a un qui sont des
records de rapidité et tout ça se trouve
sur sur facebook sur internet est tous
là j'arrive au seulement 38 aulas je
viens là un truc de la mort là aux 41 oh
[ __ ] j'ai passé basculer on reprend on
reprend parce que c'est ça ce jeu tu
sais c'est comme les petits jeux sur
mobile où tu peux pas t'empêcher de
reprendre là c'est pareil mais en mieux
par mille fois mieux parce qu'en plus tu
as l'objet dans les mains
[Musique]
là je suis je suis arrivé au 59
c'est à dire en fait c'est l'équivalent
du drop iii comprend le groupe pro après
évidemment le but c'est de faire de hao
sent directement en prenant son temps et
après c'est de faire du 1 au sens
directement le plus rapidement possible
[ __ ] oui on l'a passé auquel 63 64
alors le 65 c'est la spirale infernale à
l'intérieur qui le fait tomber dans le
petit pot des familles du 66 voyez aller
la voir mais peut-être c'est plus simple
de votre côté nancy seul hélas en
déroule la spirale de l'autre sens qui
nous fait arriver ici et ici et là vous
remarqué qu'au niveau du 68 ya pas de
bordure de ce côté là donc il faut faire
attention et ça nous fait arriver aux 69
[Musique]
soixante dix adhérents repos on reprend
on reprend donc aux 60 parce qu'on peut
s'y regrouper que 60
allez c'est reparti pour 60 taktak au
moins que j'aille jusqu'au 90 quoi
[Musique]
savent pas vraiment ce pourrait le faire
en live sur twitter
ok mais à mais c'est dégueulasse là
qu'il soit pas tombé dedans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah [ __ ] c'est chaud 72 bon moi je vous
propose de continuer sur la chaîne
twitch celui ci le continuera en live
sur la chaîne twitch vous avez le lien
dans la description et je vais vous
présenter les autres de l'eau de gamme
mais que sur la chaîne secondaire parce
que je veux pas de tous les faire ici
vous allez en avoir marre donc si ça
vous intéresse
abonnez vous tout de suite en masse à la
chaîne secondaire où il ya des trucs
très court il n'y a pas que du
casse-tête dessus il ya des choses que
vous voyez pas mais il y aura le
perplexus épique donc plus dur je n'ai
pas là près de moi et je ferai également
le rookie et à terme je ferai de harry
potter sur 7,6 ou sur sur l'autre on
verra bien bref perplexus excellent
excellent concept un très addictif très
fun ça fait travailler la concentration
ça fait travailler l'agilité j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup l'idée de
recherche pas à résoudre quelque chose
là on cherche juste à le faire avancer
au niveau de la réalisation c'est quand
même super malin quand tu vois le truc
tu dis comment il peut y avoir 100 étape
est en fait tu arrêtes pas de tout
contournée s'est super bien pensé je
vous mets un lien dans la description
pour l'obtenir saint lyé amazon il
disponible sur amazon et dans les
magasins de jouets voilà merci a vous de
me l'avoir envoyé merci d'avoir regardé
la vidéo à très bientôt ciao